you've mentioned that Malcolm X has been
in part misunderstood
um what are some aspects of him that are
misunderstood well I think reading his
autobiography is
extremely important for anyone that
wants to understand him right so you
read him in his own words
Malcolm lived the tragedy of being
a young disenfranchised black man in
America who went through all of the
difficulties that were posed
in a 1950s America
uh towards him I mean he went through
the system and it was
awful for him and he had to pull himself
out of that and make himself into
an incredible orator an incredible uh
leader
uh that suddenly had a pretty empowering
vision and a calm and and nonetheless
courageous but a calm presence to him
uh and was able to bring together people
especially uplift black people in
America to believe in themselves
uh young young men in America in America
and in prisons in particular will read
the autobiography of Malcolm X and see
hope for themselves to come out of the
darkness
of you know being in prison not just by
the bars in front of them
but also uh by what they thought to be
their own worth prior to that moment and
so Malcolm climbs out of uh that and he
goes through multiple phases so
Malcolm dies as an orthodox Muslim
who does not believe in the superiority
of One race over the other
finds great Tranquility in the practice
of the Hajj
um great clarity and I think you read
his letters from Mecca
and he talks about his his change his
transformation in particular and it was
a process it's it's a process for him
but he inspires the likes of Muhammad
Ali to become the person that he becomes
and inspires many other people
uh till today
to really
see themselves and see the world
differently in light of that
understanding of monotheism
so he was deeply a man of faith and
throughout his life the nature of that
faith has changed as he grew as he
interacted with
I would say a cruel society that he was
living right